salut à tous bienvenue sous les
cocotiers de Saint-Paul pour vous parler
d'une discipline clé glisse sur l'eau et
des Champions il y en a trois sur le
plan national d'Européens des
disciplines dans tous les sens et pour
nous en parler Christophe lefour et toi
ta passion c'est quoi le ski nautique
c'est parti
faire la Tour Eiffel
un bateau sur un sur un fleuve on a
commencé un petit peu comme ça et puis
après de fil en aiguille c'est monté la
passion du ski pour la glisse Christophe
à 34 ans de ski dans les jambes
simplement vice-champion du monde de
saut une référence mondiale qui fait
grandir nos athlètes depuis 15 ans sur
le bassin de Saint-Paul
au fait
je vais j'arrive
le niveau est bon comme vous le voyez
derrière moi les courses enchaînent car
ici ça se passe sur rendez-vous
en tout cas sachant de savoir qu'est-ce
qui passionne c'est sportif
mon grand-père a acheté un bateau à mon
père et j'ai commencé sur les épaules à
mon père et à 5 ans on a demandé à en
faire avec des ski adultes parce que ça
existait pas les skis en fort et
aujourd'hui c'est les miens que j'amène
pour goûter au même sensation puisque
c'est carrément un sport c'est très bien
qu'est-ce qui sollicité le bassin les
cuisses les avant-bras et tous les
muscles quelle sensation tu as d'être
libre sur le
belle manifestation annuelle
tous les ans donc nous faisons une
manifestation une compétition qui
classer qui est sur le classement
international donc cette année on a eu
trois des dix meilleurs ce qui est hors
mondiaux qui étaient là et bon ben c'est
c'est un plus ils ont été époustouflés
par la Réunion ils diffusent des films
partout sur Youtube donc c'est une
superbe publicité pour sa Paul et en
même temps bon on a aussi beaucoup
d'aide on est très soutenu par le
Conseil régional que je remercie
profondément et le CNDS aussi la
Jeunesse et Sport bon Christophe on
s'est bien amusé mais maintenant quand
c'est que ça on voit et ben là on va
voir des jeunes qui vont envoyer un peu
plus et je vais faire aussi un petit
tour pour envoyer du gros et bientôt à
vous sur l'eau il y a de tout comme
discipline il y a de quoi faire plaisir
à tout le monde oui tout à fait avec le
wakeboard les figures le slalom on peut
essayer aussi le vert donc c'est
élargi on a pour tout le monde vous avez
compris Christophe il faut pousser la
porte allez c'est parti allons-y
sur l'eau être au-dessus de cette
matière liquide et s'exprimer outre les
trois disciplines du ski d'autres plus
fun sont de plus en plus présentes et
séduisent un nouveau public